oh my gosh guys the spiderman no way
home trailer just dropped i'm gonna
watch it right here on freaking twitter
because that's where i saw it first
let's take it look see here what exactly
is gonna happen i'm so glad it came out
today i was a little worried but here we
go
they give us this little teaser oh my
gosh it looks so cool they give us a
little teaser and we're gonna okay okay
this is a good one some suggest that
parker's powers include the male
spider's ability to hypnotize females
[Music]
i did not
[Music]
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide before
[Music]
oh snap
they catch him right after it looks like
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of
i'm people about how to fix all of this
that's good
it's okay
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry my
father you sir please we're safe to have
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird that'll allow it
oh snap
whoa
i was wondering if maybe you could relax
underground i was about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mgm's gonna forget about everything
you've ever been through stop tampering
with the spa this is just
holy crap
what just happened
holy crap spider-man
whoa it's you trying to live two
different lives
[Music]
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for a partner
show them
hello
[Applause]
oh my god
okay oh my gosh that basically like
confirms like freaking everything like
everything excuse me i'm sorry
oh my gosh oh my gosh pumpkin bomb but
there is a part in there i want to i
want to rewind real quick real fast
before i get to the
before i get to the breakdown where
what was that a portal opened up
and there was like somebody behind him
trying to live two different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
there who's that
it looks like the green goblin
oh and behind it looks like
it looks like it's right where he died
oh and that lightning bolt freeze for a
minute oh
freaking like oh there's the new suit
you can see you can see the new suit
there the black and uh gold one dang
electros fighting him and then the
pumpkin bomb oh my gosh all right okay
oh
let me know what you think about it down
below okay it didn't show the other two
spider-man tell people andrew garfield
but obviously they're going to save that
for last uh i'm 100 million convinced
com million percent convinced that
they're going to be in it because one
source has told me this this confirms
that the spider verse outfit molina's
got the pumpkin bomb green goblin
william defoe's green goblin is
returning electro we saw the the
lightning blast oh my gosh like i cannot
believe
they showed all that i'm actually
shocked how much they showed so all
right gotta get started on my breakdown
love you all so glad it came out tonight
let me know what you think about it down
below subscribe so you stay up to date
on everything spiderman related and mc
related as always thank you so much for
watching woof